Kevin quark is standing by with the
latest we've been watching this news
unfold all night in Washington DC we
have now confirmed tonight the press was
told to leave the White House at 8:45
p.m. by the Secret Service here with the
full report and you could see the
protests ongoing obviously attempt now
in Washington DC to a lot of things
going on there Kevin what's going on
well let me tell you two things you're
right about 8:45 or so the Secret
Service told the White House press corps
to evacuate now usually what that means
Shawn is if you're out there on the
North Lawn you don't want to be downwind
of any dispersal techniques in other
words if they're gonna use pepper or
some other agent they want to clear an
area especially when there are lots of
people they don't want you on the North
Lawn or it could also mean and sometimes
it does that protesters have gotten too
close to the fence line I don't believe
that was the case but as you've known
Sean the mob is in fact on the move in
fact they're trying to do 2dc what
they've done in Seattle let's create an
autonomous zone they're calling this one
wait for it Black House autonomous zone
they tried to actually set up shop just
north of the White House about a block
east of Lafayette Park using barricades
that were already there Sean thanks to
DC's mayor Muriel Bowser who cordoned
off a part of 16th Street renamed in
black lives matter Plaza so they sort of
scooted those barricades over along with
some fencing however the separatists
have been hit by a massive law
enforcement presence so at this hour
it's still unclear how much autonomy
they may be able to secure sources on
the ground in fact are telling us that
there are dozens and dozens and again
dozens of men and women in uniform in
that area we've got a crew on the scene
as you see there and as we get pictures
we'll pass them along meanwhile Sean I
want to tell you this very quickly
authorities have also moved in to save
the statue of Old Hickory Andrew Jackson
anarchists and other protesters deface
the statue of the seventh President of
the United States and they tried to pull
it down that too was right there and
Lafayette Park were directly across from
the White House thankfully law
enforcement moved in to push back the
mob and to protect that historic statue
I'm gonna make my way over there and see
what else I can learn on the ground if I
get more before your hours up I promise
to pass it along Sean but for now back
to you all right we're gonna be checking
in and out
we'll head to Seattle in just a minute